[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique on
parle sport aujourd'hui en débat le
fonctionnement le financement la
pratique physique les équipements
l'image et la communication des
collectivités territoriales sans oublier
les grands événements populaires
trois invités sur ce plateau pour
débattre tout d'abord jacques mariot de
le sbf le sbf c'est l'entente sportive
bisontine c'est le club de handball
féminin de besançon et de franche comté
il est membre du comité directeur
christophe rault pied des républicains
et vice président chargé des sports apm
à ces pays de montbéliard agglomération
et puis denis mercier
c'est le président du cci n o ça vous
dit certainement rien mais c'est le club
sir qui cliquent cycliste qui organise
le cyclo cross de nommer n'oubliez pas
que vous pouvez commenter l'émission sur
twitter grâce au hashtag dit mme paul fc
comme dimanche en politique franche
comté alors je vais tout d'abord me
tourner vers le politique de cette
émission
christophe rault pied vous êtes
maintenant donc élu avec de lourdes
responsabilités
vous avez encore le temps de faire du
sport c'est une bonne question
oui plus beaucoup plus beaucoup mais
vous vous posiez du foot c'est noble et
du tennis de table
jacques mariot vous vous avez été en
valeur et qu'elle en valeur à besançon
vous avez encore le temps de faire du
sport à moi j'étais handballeurs j'étais
footballeur j'étais athlète au départ
donc j'ai même fait du décathlon et
maintenant parce que je me suis laissé
dire que vous faisiez du bûcheronnage
normes epa hausse et une activité
physique mais elle veut plus de sport en
tant que tel je fais de l'activité
physique avec mes tronçonneuse et mon
tracteur voilà donc c'est une forme
effectivement pour être en bonne santé
et en bonne forme alors denis mercier
vous votre truc c'est le cyclisme vous
avez été coureur durant plus de 20 ans
vous organisez maintenant le cyclo cross
de nommer vous êtes venu chez vous
jusqu'à besançon en vélo non non non ça
ce plus guère possible oui vous en
faites encore quand même a pris 4 5
mille kilomètres dans l'année maximum
c'est bien ça 4 à 5000
c'est déjà pas mal mais c'est bien
activité physique c'est déjà une bonne
preuve d'endurance moi c'est juste du
vélo d'appartement je peux pas vous dire
combien je fais de kilomètres à l'est on
passe à la première partie de cette
émission alors la première partie c'est
déjà les règles du jeu on va planter le
décor de ce qui se passe en bourgogne
franche comté maintenant oui j'ai les
chiffres de bourgogne franche comté pas
que de franche comté à savoir que dans
notre région il ya six cent trente mille
licenciés et 7600 associations ou clubs
alors on va parler comme un petit peu
argent déjà pour commencer cette
émission avec vous jacques mariot alors
on m'avait dit en préparant cette
émission que vous le seul salaire que
vous ayez perçus en tant que
handballeurs c'était une paire de
baskets et vous étiez très très content
de la voir là aujourd'hui le budget de
le sbf c'est un million et demi d'euros
la moitié de subventions la moitié de
partenariats privés
est-ce que vous avez de moins en moins
de subventions justement des
collectivités je crois qu'aujourd'hui de
collectivités font font le maximum pour
nous soutenir je pense qu'elles ont bien
compris aujourd'hui que le sbf était le
clubber à dire phare de la région de
franche-comté gérer même d'abord une
franche comté puisqu'on est lé seul en
première division
nous avons retrouvé l'europe l'année
dernière nous la retrouvons encore
l'année prochaine
c'est toujours deux mille spectateurs
3000 spectateurs quand c'est la coupe
d'europe donc le pain des sports et là
est un engouement autour du sport
féminin alors que les collectivités ne
suive
quel pays vous n'avez pas dire du mal
des collectivités de vous avez été
adjoint au commerce à à la ville de
besançon
mais malgré tout elle diminue leurs
subventions d'année en année où vous
vous estimez vous êtes bien lotis sinon
elle ne diminue pas les maintiennent
vingtaine d'heure suivant leurs
subventions la ville de besançon
rapporte 390 mille euros le conseil
départemental environ 150 milles le
grand besançon
30 30 milles et puis la région de
bourgogne franche comté à porto
également son de l'argent sans amis la
pop 120000 plus sont un centre de
formation labellisée par la fédération
est reconnue par la région de bourgogne
franche comté qui nous apporte encore
cent mille euros environ pour ce centre
de formation
denis mercier donc comme je disais vous
vous êtes l'organisateur du célèbre
cyclo-cross de nommer kiêu pour les
championnats de france ou même pour pour
les championnats du monde alors un
cyclo-cross déjà aux dés
pas la fédération française de cyclisme
vous demande cent mille euros et au
total c'est plus de 200000 euros pour
organiser cet événement vous faites
comment pour trouver des sous dans le
financement il ya environ 40 45 % des
financements qui est apporté par les
collectivités en l'occurrence pour ce
qui nous concerne c'est l'agglomération
du pays de montbéliard pma celle avait
presque le trésorier en face
effectivement que notre temps nous avons
sylla la région la grande région
bourgogne franche comté est le conseil
départemental du doubs un peu cette
depuis quelques depuis deux jours
maintenant un peu le conseil
départemental de la hauteur vous
laisseront will même la haute soule
est ce que la haute saône se revendique
comme étant une terre de cyclisme
est ce que vous voyez une diminution des
subventions ou comme jacques mariot vous
dit bon on s'en tire pas trop mal mais
on s'en tire bien je pense que vous êtes
le haut du panier
13' bon je ne vais pas parler à la place
de mes collègues organisateurs ni
présidents de clubs en ce qui nous
concerne
peut être est ce tout simplement liées à
la notoriété de la manifestation à
l'impact à son impact médiatique à ce
qu'elle apporte sur notre territoire
dans le nord franche comté mais en tout
état de cause je peux pas me plaindre
pour ce qui me concerne 2 les
subventions sont maintenus chaque année
elles sont battues à vélo nouveaux
financeurs en face de vous ce serait pas
très poli douala ne connais bien je veux
dire est si c'était si qui s'offre aux
pieds donc vous êtes l'un des
participants financier au cyclo-cross de
nommer quels sont les critères qu'un élu
comme vous ou comme d'autres retiennent
pour justement financer tel ou tel
évènement tel ou tel club voir tel ou
tel sportif
vous l'avez dit l'organisation du cyclo
cross à anneaux mais c'est plus de 30
ans d'organisation
c'est une équipe de plus de 250
bénévoles qui s'est lui voulu fait de
confiance voilà ça alors mais au delà de
au delà de cette confiance
denis le sait bien et il retrace bien
heures après chaque événement c'est des
millions de téléspectateurs qui suivent
l'événement chaque année enfin tous les
cas tous les deux ans pour les
championnats du monde et pour nous c'est
important pour le territoire
oui parce qu'il m'a dit donc c'est 9
millions de téléspectateurs
donc ça c'est ce que vous vous cherchez
qu'on parle de montbéliard que ce soit
du cyclo cross où que ce soit avec de la
voiture quoi entre autres entre autres
mais c'est vrai que l'attractivité de
notre territoire
si on peut justement dynamise dynamiser
cette attractivité par le sport
allons-nous finances effectivement donc
c'est de la communication c'est l'image
tout à feu on va voir maintenant
justement que cette compétence ce sport
elle est partagée entre les différentes
collectivités
c'est à dire qu' aucune collectivité ne
doit favoriser l'action en direction du
sport
donc est ce que comme personne n'est
vraiment en responsable est ce que tout
le monde se décharge sur le voisin donc
je pense que les deux nuls vous le dira
aussi bien que moi il faut un
déclencheur est le déclencheur le local
on va dire c'est l'agglomération qui
permet aux organisateurs d'aller voir
les autres collectivités de façon à
pouvoir soutenir leurs événements alors
on peut parler du cyclo cross ce mario
et là on pourra parler du championnat
d'europe de handball qui aura lieu fin
d'année ce mois de novembre
voilà handball féminin handball féminin
méline de l'élite il ya poule
préliminaire du championnat d'europe
il a fallu à une collectivité chef de
file c est l agglomération et ensuite
les autres collectivités que sont les
villes les départements jeudi les parce
qu'il ya aussi le territoire de belfort
et la ville de belfort dans la boucle et
la région nous on nous ont suivis c'est
vraiment ce cette dynamique collective
qui a fait que cet événement a pu à a pu
arriver sur le pays de montbéliard
réjouissait alors en début de semaine le
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté a reçu les athlètes qui avaient
participé aux jeux olympiques donc en
corée et pour les mettre à l'honneur
alors faut savoir que côté régional
consacre 9 millions ou d'euros à son
budget ce sport en bourgogne franche
comté et puis à cette occasion c'était
lundi j'ai rencontré laëtitia martinez
la vice présidente chargée des sports au
conseil régional je vais demander
justement ce que faisait cette
collectivité pour le sport
très bien sur le sport de haut niveau et
puis j'ai posé la même question à la
présidente du cross le comité régional
olympique et sportif
comment financer le sport vous allez
vouloir elle elle parle plutôt de
mutualisation on écoute on a mis en
place un appel à projets ouverts à tous
les clubs de bourgogne franche comté
dont quand même plus de 6600 club en
bourgogne franche comté pour toutes
celles et ceux qui s'engagent sur tout
ce qui est autour du sport pour tous la
citoyenneté l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes des actions particulières
dans les quartiers politique de la ville
en zone de revitalisation rurale tout ce
qui est en faveur du handicap également
du développement de la pratique
handisport sur tous ces aspects là toute
cette dimension résolument citoyenne et
de cohésion sociale
on a un appel à projet qui est dédié on
aide aussi les collectivités
territoriales dans leurs équipements
sportifs pour l'aménagement du
territoire donc il n'ya pas un ou deux
critères c'est vraiment en fonction de
qui porte le projet parce que la
politique sportive
c'est une politique globale c'est pas
une politique de guichet c'est une
pratique qui a du sens et qui répondent
aux besoins des territoires et de leurs
populations
en effet nous allons avoir de moins en
moins une subvention donc je pense que
la mutualisation est une solution parmi
tant d'autres et il va falloir que je
pense qu'on travaille autrement qu'on
cherche des partenaires privés ce que je
pense 4 si on n'était pas très très bon
donc je pense là il faut qu'on
s'améliore c'est à dire que je me prends
un exemple que le basket travail et que
le hand que le foot travail avec la
lutte
voilà c'est là dessus la mutualisation
dans tous les sports
[Musique]
alors vous vous regardiez tous les deux
vous étiez un peu interloqués vous voyez
pas faire des événements semblables
je pense qu'un chaque sport à son
identité on peut pas comparer le basket
entre guillemets sport américain avec
tout ce qui est autour
et puis le handball handball si minsk
est beau les audi handball déjà laissé
les jacks donc à une consonance g vous
ne voyez avec denis mercier mon puisque
vous connaissez dans la vraie vie vous
voyez pas vous monter un événement
ensemble c'est difficile de concevoir du
handball en salle et puis le cyclo cross
en plein air monsieur mercier c'est quoi
le but at-il là je suis dubitatif le bon
j'ai rien contre la mutualisation sur le
principe je pense que ça peut être une
solution à terme si si si d'aventuré ils
vont semble se réduire et qu'on en soit
obligé de consommer d'en passer par là
peut-être jeu mais je suis un peu
sceptique quand même sur la possibilité
de travailler ensemble avec des sports
qui ont chacun d'entre eux leurs
spécificités ça me parait est compliqué
tout ça on a d'autres idées pour rien
vous cacher alors c'est quoi les autres
résidus malaisie ces concerts avec avec
christophe frappier on a on a choisi de
maintenir l'organisation d'épreuves de
haut niveau en franche comté est de
garder le standing des épreuves que nous
avons organisées jusqu'à aujourd'hui
les coupes du monde en particulier où
les champions de france en les
organisant qu'une année sur deux faut
que j'explique là pour ceux qui sont pas
au fait du milieu du cyclisme que entre
besançon et nommé y avait une petite
compétition une petite rivalité
il ya deux ans on qui a organisé aussi
son cyclo cross et vous vous avez voulu
jouer un peu les juges de paix en disant
nous a nommé on fera une année sur deux
et on laisse l'autre année à besançon
c'est ça l'histoire l'histoire c'est un
peu ça oui je pense que le la
problématique chez nous en franche-comté
f16 qui devrait pas être une vraie
problématique puisque on a la chance
d'avoir deux organisateurs qui ont des
compétences pour accueillir des épreuves
de haut niveau voire de très haut niveau
nous sommes tous les deux ses
organisateurs dont la même région dans
le même département
il ya donc trois des médias à citroën
non non non non il ya 3 il ya deux des
trois principaux financeurs qui sont les
mêmes le département du doubs et la
régie bien sûr alors l'hypothèse on
organise chacun d'entre nous organise un
événement majeur sur la même année
civile
ça veut dire qu'on va solliciter dans la
même année civile
deux fois les mêmes là on va poser la
question à christophe rault pied vous
quand vous avez vu ça que besançon
monter son propre cyclo cross vous avez
décroché votre téléphone vous avez
appelé jean-louis fousseret le maire de
besançon en lui disant qu'est ce que
vous faites là jean louis non non du
tout je pense que les présidents des
deux structures sont assez grands pour
eux pour s'entendre voilà puis cela
était le cas les comme vous avez vu que
ça arrivait à besançon vous êtes fait un
peu d'inquiétude pour nommer oui un peu
d'inquiétude mais c'est surtout
aujourd'hui on a on a un club qui existe
et qui est historique sur le sur le pays
de montbéliard et sur le nord franche
comté
donc je crois qu'il fallait discuter
c'est vrai que l'effet d'annoncé a pu
nous faire peur à un moment donné on a
encore dû cette année que on avait une
organisation qui était au top sur le
pays de montbéliard mois de janvier
c'est au mois de janvier
allez je vous propose de passer à la
deuxième partie de cette émission à
savoir donc le sport une histoire
d'image et son évolution
[Musique]
oui jean paul mario vous vouliez
intervenir
c'est jacques parent dont jean paul
c'est votre frère j'étais sûr que
j'allais la faire c'est mon jeu me voilà
qui est maire de port sur saône voilà
vous savez tout ce que je voulais dire
ce qui peut rassembler les clubs
sportifs c'est l'image du sport c'est
l'éducation par le sport c'est rentré
d'un coach sportif qui soit cyclo-cross
de basket de volley de handball c'est
dire bonjour monsieur merci au revoir et
l'éducation par le sport à travers les
clubs sportifs c'est un élément du
triptyque de l'éducation en général d'
de l'enfant et de la famille au même
titre que l'alcool et ça c'est capital
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui dans les
collectivités notamment dans les
quartiers où c'est plus difficile
d'avoir des clubs sportifs et je pense
que l'argent public là il serait
effectivement très très important dans
l'est pour créer effectivement toute
cette dimension est ce lien social que
permet de faire le sport
alors je vous propose justement d'écouté
maintenant jean-luc gantt nerfs il est
journaliste à france 3 franche comté il
suit beaucoup les sports j'aimerais vous
faire réagir à ce qu'il va dire la
pratique sportive a beaucoup évolué et
70% maintenant des français veulent
pratiquer un sport mais de manière
totalement autonome
on écoute on part dans un état
sur le terrain des infrastructures qui
sont des patinoires des piscines des
gymnases etc qui sont gérés par des
clubs en général avec un système
d'heures pour différents clubs pour une
salle c'était on passe de ça à des gens
qui veulent totalement libre
indépendante pratiquer ce qu'ils veulent
quand ils veulent et comme ils le
veulent elle souhaite savoir si c'est
bien si les vertus du sport continue de
se transposer dans ces mutations là ça
c'est une vraie question politique à se
poser et bien justement monsieur mario
jacques mariot alors c'est ça le
problème
les gens maintenant font de l'activité
physique tout seul je pense qu'il ya une
confusion dans les termes
entre sport et activité physique lorsque
vous pratiquez une activité le dimanche
matin vous mettez votre short vous
prenez votre vélo vous faites de
l'activité physique mais vous ne
disparaît pas du sport a une finalité et
jenny qu'une faillite et finalité
esthétique par rapport à un bien-être
par rapport à la santé
quant au fait du sport on est par
rapport à des normes et par rapport à
une compétition par rapport à d'autres
donc l'activité physique aujourd'hui
c'est le terme qu un peu galvaudé alors
c'est vrai comme on n'en fait plus qu'il
ya 20 ans fait beaucoup plus abritée
physique aujourd'hui parce qu'on se rend
compte aujourd'hui que l'activité
physique dans le chemin de vie de chacun
d'entre nous ça devient une nécessité
absolue
quel que soit l'âge on doit commencer
très tôt par rapport à l'éducation et
continue est beaucoup plus tard par
rapport à des problèmes cardiaques les
problèmes de respiration pulmonaire et
c'est donc le l'activité physique
aujourd'hui doit doit poursuivre suivre
le chemin de vie de tout tout cas la
personne jusqu'à son décès denis mercier
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
que dit jean luc à savoir une
interrogation est-ce qu'on peut
transmettre des valeurs sportives de
respect par exemple sans être membres
licenciés dans un club c'est plus
difficile est évident je rejoins
complètement jacques mariot sur ce point
de vue c'est effectivement le
le pratiquant d'activité physique il est
livré à lui même mais il est pas il
n'est pas souvent encadré effectivement
les vraies valeurs du sport on les
trouve et entend les gens qui font
qu'ils font du jogging ou du jeu ils
vont participer à ce grand événement
ensemble avec plusieurs centaines voire
plusieurs milliers de personnes
mais même ça ça suffit pas selon vous
non non et quelques-uns d'entre eux
seulement 1 et tous ceux qui pratiquent
une activité sportive n'ont pas
forcément à un moment donné ou un autre
envie de s'aligner sur des grandes
compétitions sur des grands sur des
grands événements sportifs
si populaire soit qu'ils laissaient pas
c'est pas une évidence christophe
retient qu'est ce que vous en pensez
oui je crois qu'il en faut pour il en
faut pour tout le monde vous parlez des
grands événements sportifs le lion qui
se déroule sur le pays de montbéliard
c'est un bel essai en compétition de
demi fond voilà qui représente quatre ou
cinq mille coureurs chaque année donc je
pensais aussi à la transju ghazi la
transjurassienne la forestière enfin
voilà plainte j'ai plus de facilité vous
parle pour vous parler de vue du lion
puisque c'est chez nous j'ai pas fait la
transjurassienne dix fois la devise
inquiétez pas raison sur les 5000
participants il ya des compétiteurs et y
avait il ya des gens qui courent une
fois par semaine les joggeurs du
dimanche mais voilà et qui vont pouvoir
prendre du plaisir à dimanche aux
participants lyon alors quand même la
question jusqu'à maintenant des gens
aller faire du sport d'oran des clubs
dans des structures des gymnases des
piscines des patines ans et c est ce que
vous en tant qu'élu vous pensez à
l'évolution de cette pratique sportive
et vous vous dites il va peut-être
falloir qu'on revoie les choses oui
alors oui on est en plein dedans
aujourd'hui au niveau de l'agglomération
avec le contrat de ruralité
puisqu'on en train d'aménager des pistes
cyclables donc voilà on pense aussi aux
gens qu'ils qui veulent aller se
promener faire du vélo en famille
pratiquer une activité physique sans
forcément que cette activité sadien delà
de la compétition tout simplement oui on
y pense bien sûr dans le sport si je
peux rajouter dans l'éducation sportive
il y a en plus s'il voulait le respect
le goût de l'effort le dépassement de
soi même
l'exemplarité tout ça ça fait partie
aussi de
tout ce volet éducatif que permet le
cadre sportif le cadre éducatif quelle
association sportive le club sportif et
c'est pour ça qu'une pratiques
libertaires du dimanche matin rien
contre au contraire il en faut pour tout
le monde mais on n'a pas les mêmes
contraintes et moi je pense que
l'éducation d'une manière générale de
l'individu ça passe par par des niveaux
de contraintes et des petites et des
petites choses qui font que
on se construit en tant que citoyennes
citoyens pour le pur pour la vie en
société
est-ce que donc le sport donc que vous
avez l'air de dire joue un rôle
d'éducation il joue un rôle social aussi
dans les quartiers tout à fait c'est un
licencié vous on a 300 licenciés filles
ma fille chez les garçons c'est à peu
près la même chose ce qui est un peu
dommage c'est que comme je disais tout à
l'heure c'est que dans les quartiers
c'est toujours difficile d'aller
chercher des jeunes garçons et des
jeunes filles dans les quartiers et moi
je pense que j'en reviens cet argent
public créé des clubs sportifs et avec
des animateurs payés par les
collectivités
ça je pense que ce serait ça permettrait
à faire que nos quartiers soient a donné
de l'oxygène parce que l'éducation ne
commence là alors justement on a vous
parlais tout à l'heure de l'action du
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté même quand la franche comté était
seul nom associé à la bourgogne
beaucoup d'argent a été investi dans
prémanon dans shaun avec c est ce que
c'est pas justement au détriment des
petites structures des petits clubs qui
font un boulot d'éducation et social
important
oui
après manon faisait aussi d'éducation à
travers une activité sportive
spécifiques
je crois que là aussi les collectivités
elles doivent mettre de l'argent partout
parce que d'éducation touche tout le
monde et que il ya certes un sport où il
ya des vitrines comme le cyclo cross a
nommé ce sont des corps et des premiers
de cordée comme j'aimerais ses premiers
de cordée il faut leur donner un coup de
pouce pour faire qu' on puisse les
garder au plus haut niveau parce
qu'elles sont des vitrines et
l'exemplarité des joueuses je pensais de
l'usb montre aujourd'hui défi qui
s'entraîne de manière professionnelle
avec un préparateur physique à
préparateur mental préparateur gardien
de but avec kiné avec médecin il ya tout
un environnement scientifique
professionnelle autour de la
construction de la joueuse et les
résultats d'aujourd'hui c'est pas le
fruit du hasard
monsieur mercier vous voulez pas non
plus opposé élite et sport populaire
vous pensez qu'il faut aussi une vitrine
pour amener des jeunes bien sûr dans un
sport qui durera le vélo quand ma main
je pense que le aussi le cyclocross de
nommer ou au même titre que les coureurs
de cyclo-cross tels francis mourey ont
apporté beaucoup aux clubs locaux en 6
mouret franc comtois champion de france
et sur neuf fois champion de france s'il
vous plaît au même titre que notre
épreuve de nommer qui existe depuis 40
ans et qui a accueilli à onze reprises
la coupe du monde quatre fois les
championnats de france et s'il faut à
coupe de france est aussi une vitrine
pour les pratiquants pour les pour les
compétiteurs des clubs locaux
alors on parle aussi de l'action des
collectivités le département de la haute
saône a par exemple dépensé beaucoup
d'argent pour la planche des belles
filles pour que le tour de france y
arrive il ya un osso noah célèbre qui
s'appelle thibaut pinot le département
de haute saône c'est le seul qui
progresse en nombre de licenciés en vélo
est-ce que vous pensez que ce sont ces
deux choses là qui sont l'explication il
ya pas seulement cette explication là
c'en est une
oui mais chez quelqu'un j'ai apporté
énormément à la hausse on parle par le
choix qu'il a fait dans le conseil
départemental à part le choix qu'il a
fait de
2 d'aménager la planche des belles
filles le site de la planche des belles
filles qui qui occupe une place de choix
dans le tour de france et on sait que le
tour de france
on connaît la médiatisation du tour de
france qui est le deuxième en dehors de
dd année où il ya la coupe du monde de
foot qui est le deuxième événement le
plus médiatisé de la planète est
aujourd'hui le la planche des
belles-filles c'est quasi l'alpe d'huez
en terme de notre vie est comme vous y
allez oui oui non non c'est pas c'est
pas du communisme c'est vrai c'est vrai
et s'il ya beaucoup de gens qui est
aujourd'hui si vous vous promenez sur
les roues du de la haute saône depuis
depuis quelques depuis que le tour de
france est arrivé à la planche des
belles filles
il ya des chaque week-end des centaines
de cyclistes venus de partout de des
pays bas de la belgique de suisse
d'allemagne et de france aussi qui
viennent reconnaître ce ces routes de
haute-saône cette planche des belles
filles dansent pour vous en tant qu'élu
monsieur frau pied ça c'est l'argent
bien investi
même si ça coûte très cher une étape du
tour de france on m'a dit 400 mille cinq
cent mille euros pour pour l'étape
oui tout à fait c'est aujourd'hui je
crois que il n'y a pas de secret dans
une entreprise quand vous avez une
entreprise il faut investir pour la
développer et aujourd'hui les
investissements dans le sport c'est la
même chose c'est qu'il faut que les
collectivités puissent investir dans sur
des équipements pour pouvoir développer
on l'a fait récemment derrière avec une
association qui s'appelle l'ascap on a
investi on a participe à
l'investissement des deux terrains de
paddle
je ne sais pas si ça vous parle
catherine des terrains de paddle le
paddle je vois ça en mer voilà c'est
celle du stand up paddle ou et le paddle
c'est un mélange de tennis et de squash
ou vous pouvez à 4 vous faire plaisir
faire de la compétition du loisir et
l'agglomération a participé aux côtés du
du club à l'investissement avec la ligue
et je crois que c'est dans le cadre
aussi du développement du tennis qui
avait tendance à avoir un peu de une
perte de vitesse ces dernières années et
là on le sent on le voit en espagne avec
les licenciés lites east comme le sport
c'est ça que vous voulez dire
alors c'est un peu plus populaire c'est
vrai qu'on peut on peut le faire en
famille avec un niveau moyen
que c'est important de se mettre un peu
à la page et de participer à cet
investissement pour pouvoir relancer
effectivement une activité qui avait
tendance à peu a diminué depuis quelques
années là on parlait d'une étape du tour
de france
montbéliard ou pays de montbéliard qui
accueille une étape du tour de france
c'est pas pour tout de suite
alors mais le fort s'est positionné on
est toujours on est toujours preneur
d'une étape du tour de france
vous savez quand vous avez une étape du
tour de france qui vient la planche des
belles-filles montbéliard en profitent
également c'est tous les hôtels du
dollar urbaines du nord franche-comté
tous les restaurants qui sont qu'ils
sont en vie dessous tout à l'heure nous
disait que le territoire haute saône
avait aidé pour le cyclo cross de de
nommer est-ce que vous vous aimez lahoud
saute pour mon dossier loire la
haute-saône vol adoptive krattinger vous
avez d'aucun financeurs potentiels juste
jusque là donc vous pensez que dépenser
beaucoup d'argent sur un coup de
communication d'image ça sert à quelque
chose quand même
alors non j'ai pas dit ça je vous ai dit
que dépenser de l'argent sur des
événements en tous les cas sur des
équipements structurants ce que je vous
parlais d'un équipement structurant
c'est important pour pour les
collectivités monsieur mario est ce que
vous vous étiez à la mairie de besançon
donc comme adjoint au commerce et pas au
sport
vous étiez pour que la ville de besançon
distribuer 400 500 mille euros pour une
étape du tour de france
je crois que les villes ont besoin de
reconnaissance d'être situé que
le tour de france est une vitrine
exceptionnelle c'est tout à l'heure les
jeux olympiques la coupe du monde de
football le tour de france et donc que
besançon soit candidate je crois que ça
met en valeur le territoire la citadelle
et vous attention touristique que vous
allez mettre un peu d'huile pour que
nommer et besançon ne se concurrencent
pas trop en termes de cyclo cross
bah écoutez moi je ne suis pas tout à
fait aux affaires donc je c'est vrai que
ces deux compétitions les championnats
de france de cyclo cross est une belle
compétition la manche de coupe du monde
ça en est une autre
c'est vrai que sur le territoire franc
comtois de compétition de cette nature
ça met en valeur le cyclo cross avec un
champion que vous invite comme mouret
qu'importe aussi gérer et et ils vont
finir aussi je voudrais citer simplement
aussi les deux entraîneurs du sbf rafah
le terrain des sandrine donc ma fille
qui font que faire aujourd'hui on a des
joueuses qui viennent de partout parce
qu'on a deux championnes de mercy de
l'équipe merci beaucoup monsieur d'avoir
participé à cette émission
merci de votre attention et puis bon
sport si vous partez faire du sport
aujourd'hui bonne après midi à tous au
revoir
[Musique]